[Music]
hello everyone thank you for coming in
my name is Carolyn I'm product manager
on Google Cloud Storage and today we'll
talk about selecting the right storage
class for your workload whatever it
might be either content storage and
delivery big data analytics or a long
tail content that you may not be using
as much I'll have quite a few speakers
joining me on stage later on in this
presentation I'll introduce them as we
go but let's start with Google Cloud
Storage overall so GCS or Google Cloud
Storage is highly available durable and
simple object storage we see a lot of
success in DCs across different storage
classes big data analytics Condor
storage and delivery and cold storage as
well and GCS is built on exactly the
same infrastructures we use internally
at Google for different object storage
and chances are if you have not used
this before probably you've used exactly
the same technology for any other Google
products and as I said exactly similar
structures exactly the same engineers
maintaining and building building the
infrastructure same datacenters same
desk same racks and same network so we
see quite a lot of success across those
scenarios and let me walk you through a
couple examples how customers are using
this yesterday so starting from left to
right with common storage and delivery
we see quite a few customers using this
yes for serving video serving music
serving images serving any general
multimedia which is serving web sites
and static content through GCS then on
Big Data side if you have a lot of data
if you have petabyte scale 100 petabytes
scale or even exabyte scale you need to
keep your data somewhere and GCS is the
place to keep your exabyte scale data
and then run compute jobs on top of that
so we have quite a few customers who run
big data analytics that run their
customer pipelines custom workloads
they do different genomics processing
differently commerce analytics IOT
different manufacturing modeling and you
see quite a few of those examples here
and then if you look at those customers
many of them have hot data and working
datasets that they were processing
regularly but then they also have some
data that they want to archive or backup
for long term and pretty much every
single customer will have some sort of
in frequently accessed data or some sort
of cold data other than that we also
have customers that use dcs purely for
storing cold data
and long-term archive will also have
quite a few partners that use GCS to
help ingest data from one pram or help
archive different enterprise data in dcs
so this yesterday has four main storage
classes and I'll walk in detail across
all of them throughout this presentation
so starting from left to right so left
the hardest one is multi-regional
storage it's built for common storage
and delivery its G redundant so it's
perfect for business continuity
if a single region in dcs goes down or
something happens to that region you
don't need to worry about it will keep
serving your requests because your
data's Jared and n't across two or more
regions within a multi regional location
and we see customers use the storage or
streaming videos serving images and
website content and documents second
class is a regional storage class it's
built for data analytics within a single
region if you are running some compute
workloads you want to have your data
stored right next to your computer
clothes you want to have lowest latency
possible highest throughput possible and
regional storage class is the right
place for storing data for different
analytics for clothes or general compute
workloads and what of those storage
classes are built for a hot data and
they provide highest level of
availability across our four storage
classes then moving to the right you
will see two storage classes that are
built for cold or cool data so that's
near line which is built for data access
less than once a month and then it's
called line data that's accessed less
than once a year on average and we see
customers use those storage classes for
serving a long tale content or for
disaster recovery or for archive
beautiful part about those two storage
classes they have exactly the same API
as any other storage class in dcs so
it's very easy for you to integrate with
those storage classes once you start
using dcs either it's hot date or cold
data you can use any other storage class
because it's exactly the same API and
for all of our storage classes we
provide online latency so that means you
don't need to engineer around data
retrieval or anything like that because
all of the latency is consistent across
storage classes so let's go into detail
into construction delivery I'll start
with our multi regional storage and then
I'll invite product manager from
firebase to talk more about firebase and
how is helpful for content storage and
delivery
so our multi-regional storage is best
for content serving as I said before its
G R done on the cross stone regions and
we provide very simple API and very
simple pricing so it's exactly the same
API is for regional storage just provide
location name in this case it's us.you
or Asia and then you create a bucket and
start uploading data you don't need to
worry about your primary or secondary
regions will take care of all of that
it's a very simple API to use and
because data is G redundant we'll take
care of different file overs and it's
very good for a business continuity as
well because you don't need to worry
about some region going down inside of
these years so as I said we have three
multi-regional locations today so I have
a lot of different regions in Google
cloud platform and we're building pretty
much any region every month or every two
months so right now I have three
multi-regional locations that unite
multiple regions inside of them so one
of them is us the other one is EU and
third one is Asia and customers that
want to serve content either within
those locations around the world
they could choose one of those storage
storage locations so let me talk a
little bit more about that simple API
for multi-regional storage classes so
here's an example of creating a multi
regional storage class with a common
line utility it's called gsutil and I
provide a type of storage class which is
multi-regional I probably location u.s.
and then I just named my bucket
literally there is nothing else you need
to provide we'll take care of everything
else will take care of where to store
your data and you don't need to worry
about it and when you retrieve your data
again you didn't need to specify any
locations just provide your bucket name
domain name and then name of your file
that's it you don't need to worry about
routing will take care of routing within
our network you don't need to worry if
it's east-west Europe us will take care
of all of the routing on our Google
Network multi-regional storage class was
also optimized for end-user latency
because there are multiple layers of
caching that we have in dcs so even
though you might be storing data in
multi-regional us if you have customers
that are accessing the data from Europe
will cache the data in Europe and our
data centers
similarly in Asia Pacific will cache in
our data centers in Asia Pacific and on
top of that if you set your objects to
be public
we'll also catch those objects at the
edge in our points of presence we have
around hundred points of presence around
the world and we'll leverage the same
infrastructure as for other internal
Google products or for instance YouTube
and we'll cache the data in those points
of presence so your consumers in large
cities around the world will have
extremely low latency because data will
actually be served from location right
next to them in the city in terms of
price we charge very simple 2.6 cents
per gigabyte month for your data in
multi-regional storage class and it will
take care of all their applications
underneath you don't need to worry about
paying for network to replicate your
data across data centers you don't need
to worry about secondary copy or
tertiary copy everything is included in
that simple 2.6 cents per gigabyte month
price we also charge for read operations
and write operations and we've recently
decreased that price by 50 and 60
percent we decreased at half a year ago
and we have very competitive price on
storage and operations there in terms of
availability typically the storage class
runs at four nines availability and we
provide three and a half nines SLA so if
for some reason it drops within a given
month below three and a half nines
we'll pay you back for using the storage
class depending on how available it was
and it's also designed for 1190
durability all of our storage classes
are durable so you don't need to worry
about some storage class being less
durable than the other we provide the
same standard durability across all of
them turns out a lot of data is actually
being consumed on mobile phones so it's
extremely important for our customers to
be able to build applications and be
able to serve the data and consume the
data from mobile phones so I'd like to
invite Mike McDonald who is a product
manager on firebase to talk about using
Google Cloud storage with firebase API
thanks Grill how's everyone doing today
good awesome how many of you have heard
of firebase a couple people how many of
you operate mobile apps
hopefully oh come on you guys the world
is mobile first
so what firebase is oh I have a clicker
firebase is Google's mobile platform so
firebase allows you to develop your
applications on
cloud platform grow your user base using
our we have pushed notifications we have
application invites all of that kind of
stuff and we also have a monetization
platform so you can earn more money by
integrating with our products but for
those of you who are building mobile
apps how many of your mobile apps are
serving some kind of rich content so
you're serving media you're serving
images or videos all of that you need to
be able to easily upload from the user's
mobile device and then transmit those
around the world
firebase offers really great mobile
support for Google Cloud storage
through our SDKs and those SDKs when I
go to the next slide are optimized for
mobile content delivery so we handle
tricky problems like really granular
security so if you want your users to
sign in via Facebook and upload a photo
we can integrate with firebase
authentication which does server lists
sign on to Facebook and then lets you
again without a server upload directly
from your device to Google Cloud storage
to any Google cloud storage bucket we
also do that on the clients we have very
robust networking so how many of you
guys are enjoying the conference Wi-Fi
things are pretty slow are you like
trying to send tweets and take pictures
and share them with people have you had
any uploads fail it's because people
aren't doing it robustly so our networks
are gonna do or our SDKs we're gonna do
resumable uploads and I'll actually show
that because I've been having fun doing
my demo earlier over this network and so
we're gonna make sure that your uploads
and downloads get to where they need to
go even if the network is terrible
and as Carl's been talking about it's
all built for Google scale right so we
support five terabyte uploads direct
from your mobile phone and I actually
have a standing thing you can tweet at
me if someone ever finds out how to
upload five terabytes from a mobile
phone let me know cuz I have a job for
you
so let's switch over to the demo because
listening to me talk about this is
really not exciting
how many people have programmed an iOS
app or does Swift code look at all
familiar people maybe hopefully it's not
too crazy
I have over here an iPhone app and it's
gonna look really boring when I start it
up because there's nothing going on but
if you click that little camera button
it's gonna take us over to a photo
picker and what we're gonna do is we're
gonna take a picture from the phone
upload it to Google Cloud Storage and
then download it again to the device so
we're gonna do that all with firebase so
this is actually about a hundred lines
of code just as a shell all right yes
this works we are going to and I didn't
delete my sample there we go we're gonna
first upload the image so we're going to
create a reference to our fire our cloud
storage bucket and then we are going to
upload our image just using this put
method and so that takes the image that
we clicked and is gonna upload that to
Google Cloud storage we'll also add an
observer to let us know the progress
because I was noticing earlier today
it's pretty slow so what this is gonna
do is it's just gonna print out and let
us know how quickly things are going so
I will rerun that and to prove to you
that this is gonna work the app will
open up over here you will select the
photo by the way the apples system
photos are about 20 Meg's in size
they're pretty big oh and there we go
actually the internet was pretty quick
so you can see that we fully uploaded
our file let's pop over to the firebase
console and refresh the page and we can
go ahead and see we now have a folder
that says photos and we even have the
photo in there that was like one line of
code that uploaded a photo no no
clapping okay thank you slice what small
applause that's we're not done yet so
now we're going to synchronize that so
we're actually using another firebase
product it's our real-time database and
we've already written that data
basically a shareable URL for that
location in cloud storage and now we're
to download that image and display it so
all you need to do there is you can take
that URL that we synchronized via our
database and just say get the data and
there are about 20 Meg's so I'm making
sure that we have enough and then we
simply put it in our app and reload I'll
go ahead and start that back up and the
nice thing actually about the database
is it's gonna immediately take the first
photo that I uploaded last and it's
downloading it right now and there it is
so that was actually pretty quick but
because I like to live dangerously
and because I'm a millennial I have
another version of the app on my phone
and I am going to take a selfie with all
of you and let's see how long this takes
so it's uploading right now and there we
go oh I'm upside down sorry about that
but there you go so that was maybe 10
lines of code including all of the
application logic to upload and download
from Google Cloud storage on an iPhone
app thank you all very much and back to
Kirill thank you Mike so all of that is
still backed by Google Cloud storage so
that means when you're leveraging
firebase all of the data will be
transferred by Google Cloud storage will
be stored on Google Cloud storage and
transfer by Google Network so it will be
amazingly fast and it will scale to
extremely large applications that's
serving that content around the world so
let's go back to big data analytics now
so if you have a lot of data you need a
place to store it before you analyze it
and Google Cloud Storage regional bucket
is the right place to store the data so
data with GCS regional is redundant
within a given region and if you select
compute engine and GCS regional in the
same region you'll get the lowest
latency possible between those two and
it's built for data access frequently so
that means if you have some application
and process the data a lot this is the
best storage class to use similarly to
any other storage class GCS is very
deeply integrated with other products
within Google cloud platform like data
Pro ml Google compute engine genomics
even bigquery so you can potentially
store data in DC as an queried directly
out of bigquery
a federated query and a lot of customers
use the storage class to run different
pipelines and analyze their data from
either their customer plans and Google
compute engine or by our products and
because it's so well integrated it's
very easy to get started let's say when
you're migrating from Hadoop on Prem
migrating to Google cloud platform so
one of our products in Google cloud
platform is cloud data proc and it's
essentially manage spark and Hadoop
service and we have a cloud storage
connector which is HDFS compliant as
part of that product and that means it's
very easy for you to move from Hadoop
and pram to GCS and de the proc so
here's the example at the bottom of
changing your code essentially just
changing one line it's how you're
referencing a storage and everything
else all the other code will keep
working and that Cloud Storage connector
will take care of everything and you
don't need to change any other lines of
code and that solves a lot of problems
for customers because data is stored in
GCS you don't need to worry about
scaling the data over time like you
couldn't you might need to worry on Prem
the data is also accessible outside of
your Hadoop clusters you can turn it
down and your data will still be there
it's still in GCS you can turn up
another cluster and access the data so
that provides a lot of simplicity and a
lot of flexibility for our customers if
you want to read more about data proc
you can go to cloud google.com slash
data problem similarly to our
multi-regional storage which are a very
simple price of 2 cents per gigabyte
month which are all super operations and
we provide three 9s availability isolate
so as you see our SLA for regional
storage class is slightly lower than the
one from multi-regional where we provide
three and a half nines and that's
because regional storage is not G
redundant as multi-regional storage
class and it also has 11 eyes durability
it has instant access like anything else
in GCS and we have exactly the same API
that you would use across all storage
classes so once you start using regional
storage class you can easily switch to
using any other storage class but enough
hearing for me I'd prefer to hear from a
real customer so I'd like to invite
fastly over dear customer and partner
and specifically Arthur Bergman their
CEO
thank you thank you this works
hello everyone my name is Arthur Bergman
I'm CEO of fastly and we are both
secured a customer and a partner of
Google so what we are is a edge cloud so
in in the old world you know you had a
whole bunch of edge devices in your own
data center and as you're moving through
cloud
those old expensive inflexible
unreliable Hardware machines that you
had at the edge of your data center have
known no longer anywhere to live and so
that's where we come in so we complement
very well together with the central
cloud so we integrated really well with
Google so we provide caching edge
compute TLS termination load balancing
this ability as a complement to the
storage and computer and etc that you
get on another side so it works
we have inter connections with Google in
quite a few locations around the world
to the Google Network and then we have
our own pops all around the world
where we store your content process your
content defend your content to end-users
whether those are humans or machines or
etc all around the world and so could
also at some point be described as the
CDN we have they weren't really cool
things that we found with Google and is
the cloud functions so one of the core
functionality we provide right is that
you want the view that the rest of the
world has of your content to be
up-to-date so we do cache invalidation
or purging in about 150 milliseconds
worldwide and so here's a very simple
cloud function for Google Cloud storage
so when you upload or change an image or
any piece of data on Google Cloud
Storage that cache invalidation goes out
worldwide and the new content is
available from from any edge pop
completely transparently so
we we really like working with partners
who are really really good and provide
really good performance and service and
reliability to our customers because at
the end of the day we're here to provide
fantastic reliability and performance to
our customers and if we bring in
partners to work with partners who don't
that causes problems and so I went and
looked at some performance metrics that
we're collecting from Google Cloud
Storage versus Amazon s3 and this is not
a synthetic tests is actually looking at
very very large data sets of content
being fetched from both and the
difference is pretty dramatic so the
scale on the lower is different but what
you're seeing there is a average time to
first byte of three to five milliseconds
versus 200 milliseconds right and so
again this is very to two very large
data sets where we're fetching cache
misses from s3 or Google Cloud storage
and in both cases its s3 East and you
see GCS East so which is one of reasons
we really love working with Google
because this just creates a better
experience for everyone both engineers
at our customers and their end users so
the the use cases we're looking at and
we have some some pretty amazing
customers together
Spotify Vimeo and and firebases earlier
are obviously around caching caching
closer to user but also in the big data
analytics side we integrated really well
and from from a security point of view
the real-time aspects of the platform
and the integration with Google allows
you to do some some pretty amazing stuff
so well use cases are in this case
they're pretty simple basically like
Vimeo is obviously video and images
Spotify is
as people can guess a tremendous amount
of audio but there's a lot of other
things cool things that they do with us
as well we also do real-time log files
from the edge which is pretty key
because as you're moving functionality
that you used to have in your own sphere
of control you need that you know when
you had it in your own data center in
your own control you knew what was going
on in real-time and you need that once
you move it out into the cloud as well
and so we have these real-time logs that
update in about a second and we can
stream those into Google Cloud storage
and then get that into bigquery in in
pretty much real-time and something we
use internally very much so being of
seeing that the two-way integration that
just creates a really nice experience
for engineer developers and operations
so internally we use that a lot for
analyzing performance of TCP connections
between end-users and us so we see on
the order of three four million or TCP
connections per second at any given time
we'll have about 150 to 200 million TCP
connections open and we want to know as
much data about these as possible to
detect problems on the Internet route
around those problems etc and what we
ended up using is bigquery and we put in
about somewhere between about fifty and
a hundred thousand records per second
into bigquery we also use it for for
edge enforcement which will go into the
millisecond and then we have customers
who use it for in ad tech space or for
beacons they're collecting data through
fastly and then instead of having to run
their own data center like their own
servers to terminate that request and
put it into a Google Cloud storage
they're just having fastly dump it
directly into cloud storage so server
less basically
we use it for edge methanol it expect
and we provide edge security for our
customers and so we use school GCSE and
bigquery and edge logs for that and
basically very quickly can pull any kind
of report from the edge to see what
rules are hitting what kind of threats
we're seeing normally scores etc and so
and we can then expose that to our
customers so the the total pipeline of
end user fetching something from us we
don't have it we fetch it from Google if
we have it we give them we process it we
apply with our rules and logic around
that that we need to and then we log it
into Google and then we use Google tools
for analytics and so you can integrate
that with whatever pipelines you have
for other kind of analytics we're using
tableau or something like that or one of
the security packages and it works works
really well and then you can use the
standard Google visualizations that they
have to just create reports really
really fast so the the combination
really lets you build a very very
compelling replacement to kind of the
old combination of having your own
storage and then have a boring CDN out
there it doesn't actually do what you
wanted to do and either saw that and the
that combination the two-way integration
really allows you to drive a lot of
value and the value really comes from to
two points one is the the customer
experience your end user experience I
think a very important point is also the
internal engineering and product
experience right so you can it allows
your developers it allows your product
engineers your product managers to just
move faster and to get new functionality
out because all the api's all the
documentation api's functions modules
etc are just so accessible and we all
and you don't have to go through it's
kind of painful process that you
traditionally had to do to get all these
systems working together so you can
release code faster keep your engineers
happier and keep your by extension your
end users faster so we're we're big fans
of Google we use them internally we have
very big customers together and we would
love to have more of you using of us and
Google together thanks everyone Thank
You Artur
so we've talked a lot about big data
analytics and content serving but all of
those customers they have some sort of
cold data so over time they collect a
lot of data and the data may not be as
commonly used as it used to be when it
was just first generated and typically
customers would want to save money on
the data I'm sure everyone knows to save
money on their infrastructure and if the
data is not being used that often
probably you want to pay less for the
data that's why we have two storage
classes that are designed for cool and
cold data's one of them is near line
I don't know cold line I'll start with
near line here so near line is a storage
class that's designed for infrequently
access data
it provides the same instant access
speed and the same API as other storage
classes and it's extremely important for
our customers so what that means if
you're using multi regional storage
class for content serving and delivery
and then turns out not all of your data
is frequently accessed and you want to
store some of it in your line well turns
out you can use all of your integrations
you can use our partnership with fastly
to serve the content around the world or
you can use any big data tools that we
have at Google cloud platform and you
don't need to change anything because
it's exactly the same API it's exactly
the same latency you didn't do anything
extra on top of that so some typical
examples include storing historical data
and then maybe analyzing the data in the
future so sometimes you don't know how
the data might be might end up being
useful for you in the future so you want
to keep it around and still probably
have low latency and some chances to
access the data in the future customers
also using your line to serve long tail
content so if you have a lot of
different multimedia content some of it
will not be as frequently accessed as
the other ones so you can put your
called content or your long
kondeh Nearline so when your line we
charge one cent per gigabyte month on
storage and also charge for access of
one cent per gigabyte of data read out
of Nearline and if you work out those
two numbers and storage price for
regional multi-regional storage turns
out that Nearline becomes the cheapest
storage class for data that's accessed
less than once a month and that's where
the statement comes in that Nearline is
built for data that a it's accessed less
than once a month when your line we
provide a cell like you provides to nine
SLA and it's consistent API and
consistent performance like with any
other storage classes so if you've been
with us for a couple years you might
have seen near line two years ago and
back then we had four second latency in
your line and we've been working very
hard and improving performance and
reliability of new year line and any
other storage class so over last year
we've increased availability SLA on
multi-regional storage class and also
decreased latency in near line all the
way from four seconds all the way down
to instant access speed with an airline
and we're committed to continuously
improve our performance and reliability
in Google Cloud storage and those
improvements we've made with the near
line last year bring it all the way to
instant access speed allowed us to ship
a new storage class that's called cold
line we've launched it last October and
cold line is best for call data
specifically data that's accessed less
than once a year on average
similarly the near line it has all of
the integration points it has exactly
the same API but because it's built for
very cold data customers usually use it
for archive or storing multimedia source
files so if you don't expect the
transcoder your data but often you still
want to have your multimedia sources
somewhere and customers choose call line
for that scenario and also disaster
recovery and that's a very important
point with disaster recovery in case
something happens to your core data set
you want to be able to pull the data out
very quickly and usually customers
cannot use tape media for this or any
sort of media that has latency in it and
with cold line you have instant access
speed so you can start accessing the
data right away and more than that
because cold line has exactly the same
API sign out of storage class you can
start serving directly out of cold line
or using data the data that you're
storing call in for processing right
away without any delay because API is
exactly the same and customers find it
much more simpler than any other
solutions in the market that they have
they just
switch the traffic to different bucket
and they start using it in terms of
price we charge point seven cents per
gigabyte month for cold line and we also
charge five cents per gigabyte on data
access and that works out that if you
data's access less than once a year
cold line becomes the cheapest storage
class for you to use we also provide
availability SLA for cold line we
provide two nines availability is
exactly the same as an airline and we
also have minimal storage duration for a
cold line at 90 days so let me show you
a little bit about that API in that
performance so people sometimes don't
believe me do you really have exactly
the same API well it's exactly the same
here is an example of doing get or food
HTTP put with cold line and it's exactly
the same API as you've seen few slides
back with multi-regional storage you
provide name of your bucket in my case
it was cold line I was the one to claim
cold line as the name of my bucket you
provide your domain name and then your
file and that's it it's exactly the same
we pay as anywhere else in terms of
performance here's an example of reading
one megabyte out of cold line so I have
a utility that's called gsutil Google
storage utility and I run perfectly
agnostic with that utility and unloaded
one megabyte file from code line and as
you can see here it's between 150 and
200 milliseconds to download one
megabyte file which is quite impressive
many customers cannot achieve this with
their other solutions for hard data and
we achieve this with cold line less than
200 millisecond latency to pull out 1
Meg file out of coldest theory that we
have so we see a lot of customers
tearing the data from hostage to cold
storage but they can also tear their
storage from on-prem all the way to
cloud and all the way to cold line so
I'd like to invite karthik an ortho who
is director of product management from
dell MC to talk about our partnership
and hearing to Google Cloud storage so
for folks of you who don't know me my
name is Dean I'm part of the product
management team for Isilon which is part
of the Dell business unit so Iceland you
know we started as a purpose as a
company back in 2000 2001 with a focus
on trying to build out a scalable NASA
platform to serve the needs of some
specific
because right specifically to life
sciences to meet an entertainment
specifically customers who need a lot of
unstructured data and a lot of highly
throughput and highly scalable data or
time the company's grown as part of EMC
and operas delve we've got about eight
thousand plus enterprise customers using
my salon what makes Isilon unique to all
of these customers and why they continue
to to invest and buy more of iceland is
because it's it's a platform that's
highly simple to manage it's extremely
scalable we've got all of the enterprise
great capabilities that customers expect
on a platform and and all of the
enterprise grade security elements to it
everything from SEC compliance to do to
you know typical security tools so all
of the capabilities that a customer
requires on the enterprise is now all
available for your scale out nas
platforms as well right what makes all
of this very interesting to a lot of
customers is the fact that you have that
same level of efficiency and skill as
the amount of data starts to grow and
for me manage the data today you know
that the largest part of your data
that's growing is unstructured data
which is roughly growing at about as
markets as roughly about three times the
rest of the end of price right and so
being able to have a single user
experience for your data which is both
structured and unstructured is what
customers look for right and that's
going to where be from a business
perspective and from an Isilon
perspective approach approach the build
that we do right which is give customers
the exact same experience whether
they're running the data on the edge
clusters whether they're running this
the data within a code data center
whether they're running it in the cloud
right and now what makes the cloud
interesting is his customers look at at
cloud both from a data mobility
perspective and from a flexibility
perspective but also looking for four
ways to be able to offer lower-cost
storage for some of their warm a hot and
potentially even cold data right
so from an EMC perspective and from a
Dell perspective we've we've got our own
solutions we've got a product called
elastic cloud storage which allows
customers to move data between Ice salon
and an on-prem storage now what makes on
Prem storage interesting is it gives
customers the ability to
access the data within the same protocol
timeouts within the same expected
reliability and response times from the
cluster now what that means is when we
started looking at okay we've gotten
we've got an on-prem solution the form
of Isilon we've got an object platform
which is also on Prem customers are
looking for off-premise Aleutians
customers are looking for public cloud
solutions and so we've been starting we
started to look at a number of cloud
targets that we can support and a key
element is supporting different cloud
targets is can we have a cloud target
that enables customers to get the dollar
per terabyte that they need for their
storage and also can they get the
predictable SFA's and the predictable
Layton sees in terms of access to the
data right and that's what brings us to
do partnering with Google obviously as a
very important partner for us is
enabling customers to start at tier all
of their cool data from the Isilon onto
a Google Cloud storage target right so
customers today using Isilon can put
their performance data their high
throughput data on a local on purim
Isilon cluster but as the data starts to
age and the data starts to gets cool you
can start to move it off to a Google
Cloud storage target and still be able
to access it within the same namespace
that they would with the data on Prem
right well that gives customers is
essentially a seamless experience right
whether the data is on Prem whether the
data is on a different tier of storage
within the cluster or whether the data
gets teared off to a Google Cloud
storage target you get the same
experience from a cluster perspective
you have the same security credentials
you have the same enterprise features
it's largely agnostic and largely
transparent to the customer whether the
data is on Prem or whether that's in the
cloud and that's important for for a lot
of the enterprise customers and I'm sure
a lot of you can relate to that as well
is your end customers and end users
essentially are going to say here's what
I need from a storage perspective here's
the expected s ole's and here's the
expected performance characteristics
that I expect from a storage u storage
vendor go figure out how do you provide
that to me and for us being able to do
that with the vendor like Google enables
customers to make that choice of whether
they won't keep the data on Prem or in
the cloud but
actually keep it seamless for them so
we've talked about tearing data from on
prime to cold line and to near line
turns out that many customers want to
tear the data from hot storage to cold
storage as well so before we go into
tearing I'd like to remind you all of
the storage classes that we have in
Google Cloud Storage today so we have
four of them it's multi regional
regional near line and cold line so two
left ones multi regional regional are
hot storage classes multi-regional is G
redundant across two or more regions
there hundred miles apart and then
regional is designed for hot data stored
within a single region and
multi-regional is typically used for
common storage and delivery and regional
is typically for big data analytics
within a given region then we also have
two storage classes for cool data that's
near line for infrequent access data and
also have cold line storage class that's
for data that's accessed less than once
a year that's typical archive and very
cold data and across all of them we have
the same durability eleven nines we have
the same instant access speed we have
the same API across all of them
one interesting feature that we shipped
last year was object level storage class
and data lifecycle across those storage
classes so we see many customers wanting
to use multiple storage classes at the
same time and aged out their data from
hot storage to cold storage over time
and pay less over time and we've seen
customers copy the data from hot storage
to cold storage and when they decide
they need to use it they'll copy it back
and that was quite inefficient for
customers so we wanted to make it very
simple for them and simplify that they
don't need to worry about that so we've
created per object storage class with
project storage class you can keep your
bucket you can keep your name of your
objects and you just change settings on
a given object and say now this object
is an airline or now this object is
called line but everything stayed the
same so muck it's an object state in
place it's the same object name the same
bucket name the same API call so if your
application is using that object it
wouldn't notice any change and
everything will keep working as intended
and we also ship data life cycle across
storage classes you can create a simple
policy that will say if my objects are
older than 30 days or some number of
days
them to Nearline as we see a lot of
customers use their data very frequently
within first 30 days but then they no
longer use the data after that after
those 30 days and typically they would
move the data too near line and after a
longer period of time don't move with
the cold line as they don't expect to
use the data much longer so what's cool
about this project storage class and our
consistent API across those storage
classes once data ends up in cold line
you don't need to worry about restoring
it back or copying it somewhere you can
keep accessing against the same API
against the same object name and that
provides very simple solution for our
customers to do data between hot and
cold storage I like to compare us to s3
because there are quite a few areas
where we're winning so starting from the
far right is multi-regional storage and
our competitor does not have really
direct competition in that area so you
could create s3 standard with cross user
application and you would need to pay
for two original copies and you would
need to pay for network to replicate
across those two original copies and
that adds up to much higher number of
like 4.2 just for storage 4.2 cents per
gigabyte month plus network to replicate
across the regions and with us we have a
much simpler solution with
multi-regional storage just create one
bucket and we'll take care of everything
for you you don't need to pay for second
copy you don't need to pay for Network
to replicate it you don't need to worry
about failing over between those two
regions if one of them goes down we'll
take care of all of that for you and
because you provided simple API all of
our storage classes have exactly the
same API and exactly the same
performance you don't need to configure
anything extra outside of those storage
classes so then if we move to a regional
storage that's for hot data accessed
within the region we have a quite
comparable product it's GCS regional
versus s3 standard and we are slightly
cheaper than our competition around the
world and then going to infrequently
access data we have GCS near line which
is at 1 cent per gigabyte month and our
competition charges 1.25 cents per
gigabyte month so again slightly cheaper
there and then going to cold storage so
have product that's called CCS cold line
we launched it five months ago and was
called line we have the same API and the
same latency characteristics as any
other storage classes and that means
customers need to worry about
integrating with it or treating it
differently like anything else
and there is no direct competition in
that space so when customers think about
storage and comparing it to Amazon s3
usually they think it's a poster post
comparison between Google Cloud storage
or GCS and s3 but turns out with the
street need to add a lot of different
layers to compare to what GCS provides
so if you want to use really cold
storage you need to add glacier you need
to figure out how great with it you need
to restore date out of Glacier Bay
before it becomes usable if you want to
have multi-regional storage or zero down
on storage you need to use your R which
is an extra API feel you can figure
those regions and failover between them
if you want to use high throughput
Network or if you want to get high
throughput for your data you need to use
accelerated transfer and they charge
extra for that with us we don't charge
anything extra all of your data is
accelerated out of the box because we
use fantastic Google Network to transfer
your data and then if you want to use
CDN you need to include cloud front with
Amazon with us edge caching is part of
the product and as you've seen from our
tour we have fantastic latency because
of that because we have so many
different tiers of caching and it's part
of the core product that you don't need
to pay anything extra you need to
configure anything on top of that it's
just part of our simple Google Cloud
Storage to summarize we have a large
portfolio that covers many different use
cases so we have a multi regional
storage class that's perfect for condon
storage and delivery we have regional
storage class that's perfect for big
data analytics we have near line for
infrequent access data and we have
called ahead for cold data all of the
storage classes are united by the same
API the same online latency the same
network the same peering that we have at
Google now we have lifecycle across
those storage classes that you don't
need to worry about configuring or
copying any data between those storage
classes and then changing your API
everything is very smooth for you right
now and also have lots of different
partnerships that help you integrate and
help you use Google Cloud Storage in any
scenario that you might have so you can
learn more about low cloud storage cloud
Google comstar storage and you might
have heard that this morning we've
announced the much larger free trial
with Google cloud platform and also
announced free tier which includes
Google Cloud storage now so everyone has
access to free five gigabytes in
United States and it doesn't expire
there is no limit on it so it's free
tier feel free to use it and feel free
to try out Google Cloud Storage so I
have quite some time left so maybe a few
questions if there are any questions in
the audience so we had three guest
speakers so all of us can answer your
questions and I was asked if you have
any questions please stand up and walk
to the mic because we are recording so
that will hear a question in the
recording as well
thank you
[Music]
[Music]